[Musique]
joie et émotion pour ces élèves de
terminale ils ont leur baccalauréat et
le hall du lycée charles de gaulle de
dijon résonne de leurs tricks de
satisfaction c'est un grand soulagement
là je les ai eus avec mention assez bien
donc ça y est c'est fini j'ai eu mon
relevé de notes et tout va bien
parfois c'est la déception tant pis
savoir ce que j'ai pas ce travail c'est
tout on m'en prendre qu'à moi en cette
année de grève des correcteurs chacun
vérifie qu'il a toutes ces notes
d'examens mais en philosophie et en
espagnol 84 copie manque les élèves s'en
accommode
c'est un jour comme un autre placé la
note du contrôle caution mais si les
notes sont plus basses en garde samedi
contre donc voilà on a notre vrai visage
c'est pas mal de matches que j'ai faits
au bac après en même temps ça peut
répéter
cette année donc
ça changera pas grand chose les
professeurs du lycée relativise aussi la
rupture d'égalité induite par ce procédé
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir c'est d'avoir
le diplôme pour aller dans le supérieur
après je dirais que il ya les notes mais
aussi le travail qui est fournie par les
élèves et à partir au moment où même
s'il n'y a pas de note disponible
le travail est là et les résultats sont
là aussi impossible de savoir si les
copies manquantes seront rendus avant
les jurys de rattrapage programmée mardi
et mercredi prochains les élèves
concernés espèrent tous avoir une note
qui les dispense de ces oraux le
rectorat refuse de s'exprimer sur le
sujet pour certains l'incertitude et les
révisions se prolonge